this man's work it can be seen on
audience every day actually at 7:00
Eastern time when Mad Men is on almost
talk about how much your little logo
looks like Don Draper I definitely want
to talk about that let's do that right
out of the gate would you jon hamm it
does look cup was empty it would have
been better well I mean yes it would by
the way you could spill anytime you want
here you could do that but I get that
all the time
it's a little bit of a nod because we've
known each other forever it is a nod it
definitely is that and the aspect about
this that I will reveal is that is a
absolute genuine carbon copy of my
running style with the exception of my
right leg being photoshopped in to make
it look a little bit more of a shall we
say athletic okay
you a little kick out you have a little
kick out probably okay I've got a kick
out problem boy do I have a kick out
problem Jon Hamm and Beirut in theaters
near you right now it's bill I'm glad
you saw it I'm glad that you liked it
you were very kind you sent me a nice
text it's great yeah it's it's a it's a
movie that they kind of don't make
anymore it's like it's like a it feels
like a movie that would have you would
have seen like five of in the 1970s
three days of the Condor or you know
parallax view or whatever these kind of
things are but it says it's a smart
movie about politics and about like how
did we get here from there and I'm
really proud of it we made it in in God
we shot it and only like 30 some odd
days in North Africa and it was hot and
and and difficult but it we made a great
movie Tony Gilroy wrote the script Brad
Anderson directed it it's me Roz pike
Dean Norris you mentioned Shea Whigham
you know all these amazing actors he's
great in Boardwalk Empire
yeah Wigan was great in Boardwalk and
and and how was the thing that Daniel
mcbride thing Vice Principals that's
right that's my guy that's right you
shot this in Morocco obviously it's
about Beirut and you mentioned Tony
Gilroy who writes it he wrote and
directed Michael Clayton yeah and your
character in this film as a very Michael
Clayton yes similar kind of thing
negotiator who's who's
is to kind of go in and fix what can't
be fixed and when you when you talk
about sort of political situations
obviously the Middle East is a situation
that needs some fixing and and and this
what this movie really does is kind of
start starts before it all goes sideways
and then and then lives through the
aftermath and and kind of works toward
figuring out how we got to where we are
now starts in the 70s ends in the 80s
essentially and it runs in the run up to
the the Embassy bombing and the and the
Marine Corps barracks now IMing in early
eighties when you take a film like this
John they do read up cuz I this is how
good I am for good movies is when I will
then once it's over go to Wikipedia I
will go online and read more about oh
yeah you know of course which is what
Beirut did for me
fully yeah do you do that when you get
to a center like yeah and especially
when I get to shoot in a different
country or whatever you're kind of
surrounded by unfortunately I didn't get
to see much of Morocco because I was
working every day we were shooting
six-day weeks but I would see the inside
of my hotel room and I would see you
know sat that was it but going home at
night you would kind of process
everything that you were working on or
learning about and and that that's the
upside of the Internet is that that
information is at your fingertips at any
time and you can if you're at all
interested you can figure it out I did
the same thing when I did a million
dollar arm being in shooting in Bombay
in Mumbai I you're like there's so much
there's so many questions
seems like how did how did this place
how does this place work right
so it's and it's fun that's the best
part of traveling yeah and then you know
a million dollar arm well are on the
subject I mean that was a that was a
neat movie with a nice little sports
angle - yeah I do like a sports movie
I'll be I'll be dead honestly well which
is your favorite if you get it used it's
my favorite sports movie of all time yes
sir
probably the natural that's it huh I
mean there's something about that first
of all I'm a baseball guy you know this
yes I do I'm gonna st. Louis guy it's
kind of bred into US but there's
something about the kind of lyric
lyricism and poetry to that film
that's that captures all of the good of
baseball and all of the all of what it
means in America and the guy that wrote
that book we're in our Mellon but I
think his name was whoever
whoever wants to know the hearts and
minds of America had better watch
baseball because that's kind of who we
are
well I don't want to do the spoiler
alert for those who may not have read
the natural but the movie ending is
quite different shirt on the actual book
ending come on ending with him thrown
with his son and come on the thing he
blows out all the lights the ball keeps
going and then lands and his kids glove
that's it right turn him on and then you
know when he swings when when Roy Hobbs
swings and hits that home run before he
does and you see that's bleeding bhaiyya
through his through his jersey and
that's real blood unlike the sock many
many scar on his foot he's a Red Sox fan
I'd love to sort of give him grief for
that oh yeah I kind of want to talk
about it well I mean you with the carton
yes I don't want to talk about it
I'd rather talk about the sixty's
Cardinals versus the Red Sox what about
the what about your current state of the
Cardinals right there on top
they'd cart the Cardinals just swept the
Reds they're sitting on top of the
central yes Cubs are scuffling at 500
right time to be a Cardinal fan you got
to love that rape roll but anytime that
the Cubs are sending their fan base into
a little bit the rocks isms of doubt
where they lived for a hundred years
well that's the interesting thing to
John Hamm on the Rich Eisen show here is
that once Red Sox fans yes one yes they
kind of didn't know in a way what to do
with that till they were still
insufferable well they still are yeah I
get that but in terms of in terms of
Cubs fans now same day well they finally
have one you get a taste of that sweet
nectar and they're kind of like first of
all they want more right and second of
all they realize really hard do it again
even though they have a wonderful team
and best record baseball over the last
couple of years but still you got a win
do you go to one of the postseason
do you enjoy I guess the sort of post
victory wandering that's children right
now sure you enjoy that of course now
you did wear a Cardinals hat to the
World Series in Wrigley yes I did how
did that go over not great
I loved it I did to that point was and I
spoke to several Cubs fans who
introduced themselves to me like what
would you do what would you wear right
you're not gonna wear I'm not gonna wear
a Cubs hat that would be ridiculous and
and so you know again this isn't my
getting back to the movie I'm a very
good negotiator I would talk to people
and say look I talk to people
face-to-face they get your point of view
right so I can say look I'm a Cardinal
fan that's fine I'm actually rooting for
the Cubs because I always root for the
National League so I'm like if we don't
make the World Series every year we have
won 11 championships though so don't
worry about baseball - the New York
Yankees like but it's I said for you but
I can't I can't rep write a team that's
not my team would you wear a oh hi O
state hat ever funny you should bring
that up John what did I miss you lost a
bet a bet is one thing okay and by the
way yes after Game five when they won
and there was a big party yet yeah
outside Wrigley in one of the bars there
Bill Murray took my hat off my head and
threw it over the wall and into the
alley and then Eddie Vetter made me
stage dive off of table and I was like
dude I'm not a rock star they're not
gonna catch me I'm also not from Chicago
or a Cub fan and he goes it'll be fine I
was like no oh like that's a concrete
floor that I'm gonna you're wanting me
to jump off a picnic table into the
supportive fans he goes it'll be fine he
goes here where where my hat so I put
his Cup sat on and jumped in that egg I
got caught thankfully so do you think if
you did not put on any vetters Cubs huh
I would have been dropped like a hot
rock and the good news is because I love
that hat there was a little door to the
alley like a like almost like a cartoon
door and Bill Murray threw the Hat over
the wall and I went there's a door right
here and I opened on the other side
we did this you got it back Oh fantastic
back in 60 seconds with with John ham
again Beirut wait till you hear the the
film that sparked Beirut wait till you
hear the film what can we call it from
the sports over that sparked the movie
Beirut a an ice-skating film
mmm that many of the first four I think
okay because it goes natural and then
this film easily that's next in 60
seconds on the Rich Eisen show
[Music]
all right jon hamm another segment here
Beirut has been in theaters since April
11th what are you waiting for as you
point out John it's a smart movie it's a
movie it's kind of a throwback it is
definitely a throwback and Tony Gilroy
wrote and directed it meaning he wrote
it he wrote and directed Michael Clayton
which is my favorite the Bourne Bourne
series did you rogue one too he did some
additional stuff on rogue one he's a
phenomenal talent and as you mentioned
you know this this script was written in
1992 and most times when when things are
written and not made they sit on a shelf
and they kind of gather dust and no one
no one knows what to do with them this
this movie almost got made a bunch of
times in the 90s and then didn't because
of the political element wasn't
considered you know sort of box-office
worthy or whatever or right for the time
we're right for the times or was too
close to the thing happening in the 80s
and there was all these stories but Tony
wrote it because he wrote his first
script as a young kind of up-and-coming
writer was a little movie called the
cutting edge which I know is a huge
favorite of yours well I'm a big DB
sweeney he was great and eight men out
sure as Julis Joe Jackson sure and so
you know I might have used you I'm gonna
kick the tires on the car why wouldn't
you Laura Kelly and want to see a
romantic comedy about a figure skater
and a hockey player finally making it
work toe pick toe pick we all get it so
Tony wrote that skirt is up on the
screen look how young they were got
their babies so Tony Gilroy wrote that
wrote that script yeah was then
considered a Hollywood kind of hot
property right and they were like well
you need to write all the romantic
comedies and he's like I don't want to
do that I I want to write these kind of
you know more thriller you know
political things and and and so somebody
was like okay well then write what you
want to write they wrote the script and
he did a deep dive into like what was
the situation in Lebanon in the 70s and
why did it go south and like what was
the what was the beginnings of all this
and he wrote this amazing script in the
Tony will say this like he had this
amazing experience of having to come
back to it
almost 30 years later and rewrite
himself so go through it again in kind
of like eyes I don't like this so much
so much and I can do this and I can
rewrite this and so that was what we had
and he was in London working on rogue
one when we were shooting so he came
down and he punched up the script and he
we did a table read and then he gave it
to Brad our director and off we went off
you went and then now you wanted up
Morocco and you shoot this thing so
you're saying that we're not gonna see a
cutting edge - so I'm saying I think now
more than ever we can certainly try
well we're creating the buzz right now I
think that already was one actually oh
that was not was it the virtue in maurer
story by I've been told I've been told
that going all 25 million
are you serious it's called going for
gold no way at the cutting edge going
for gold 2006 they made a cutting edge
three chasing the dream Wow and then a
cutting edge for no that's not Fire and
Ice stop it and that and that's what
birth gameofthrones
Song of Ice and Fire and Ice Gates and
taupe it was the original mr. Sweeney of
house DB oh my gosh so I I know this
might be a sore subject but I could not
believe the st. Louis Blues have never
won a Stanley Cup they've never won a
Stanley Cup they were the I thought what
when last we spoke
yes on this show was last year around
this time yes and the Blues had a very
good team poised to go deep into the
playoffs which they did yes eventually
losing to the Stanley Cup runner-up
Nashville Predators I think this might
be two years ago I can't remember but we
had a good run
we missed the playoffs by one point this
year we had a lot of injuries we had a
we had a you know it's the NHL as you
well know is is it is it is about
managing injuries because you can't play
that 82 game season and not get dinged
up it's just there's way too much going
on guys get hit by pucks guys get hit by
other guys the boards that's a situation
and it's hard and we we were we came on
the bat into that equation this year but
we're gonna be
just fine we are we are its imminent and
when st. Louis wins its first Stanley
Cup yes I will be there and the place is
gonna go bonkers I know it you'll be
there with it will you make any better
put on a blues habit like at some point
I love that story man that's a fantastic
story and you're now doing a voiceover
for Ted Williams documentary yeah I PPS
they do a thing called American masters
and they were there doing the the story
of Ted Williams which not being a Boston
guy like I I knew of course who he was
but I immediately went to Wikipedia and
did a deep dive on Ted Williams as soon
as they asked me to do it and I thought
oh my gosh like this guy's story's
amazing yeah how about how about
fighting for the u.s. in Korea I'm
taking four years off of in the prime of
your athletic career and then I come
back and hit the ball like you you know
yeah no big deal yeah and he had four
hundred yeah no one's done it since well
George Brett came close he came close
but yeah there was no sense I mean that
that's that guy's story you know it's
all World War two he fought he fought
both he fought both both yeah my bad but
a fighter pilot yeah also a pilot yeah
it's no big deal like flying around the
Pacific and you know getting shot at I
will never forget in my career one of
them you know obviously I've been
fortunate to do NFL for as long as I
have but before that at ESPN that I was
there for the 1999 all-star game
remember that was we're gonna the the
home run derby with Sosa and McGwire and
was the all century team were Costner
read out the names of the all century
team that came out of the Fenway Park
garage like it was coming out of the
corn for sure right the reason why I
bring this up is Ted Williams threw out
the first pitch that night and he was
held up by I think it was Gwynn on one
arm and Griffey junior got up he threw
the first pitch to Carlton Fisk I was
staying in there and all of the all
century team converges on the pitcher's
mound and I heard him I overheard
because I had to get out there just to
hear what was going on and report on it
he asked Mark McGwire if when he hit a
ball if he hit it so hard that he could
smell the wood burning and that's where
he said that he said bass
Stickley mcguire just told me afterwards
that he'd never he'd never been asked
that because the answer was yes yeah
that's crazy I mean right there's so
many stories about and they must maybe
they're all apocryphal I don't know but
there's so many stories about how good
his eyesight was yes he could just see
the ball he says he'd say they put shoe
polish on the bat or whatever needs say
that I hit the left seam right seem like
you're just and he would be right all
the time correct yes I see the seams
like I've I played baseball terrible but
I still try and it's you know I'm
swinging in an area you know I'm
swinging at a seam yeah imagine hitting
a baseball's like target practice sure
unbelievable you know there's guys like
that
that just seems so I mean they're
mythologized for a reason but it's like
Ted Williams Stan Musial another one
obviously closer to my Cubs home base
but like these guys who were you just
like what is your what is your
day-to-day mm-hm you know stam usual
goes the same thing fights in the two
wars you know takes time off comes back
plays baseball runs the team for a while
you know manages a team for a while and
it just oh you're you're that guy that's
your life worst ways to make Stan the
man Musial no doubt about that so your
next film tag comes out in June yeah
this one's a little bit more funny that
yes one right now based on a true story
no joke about these guys who have been
playing a game of tag in their friend
group for 30 years they started as kids
they kept going through high school then
they kept going and kept going to him
they put for one month out of the year
all bets are off and you got to keep
your head on a swivel and one guy has
never been tagged that's the character
played by jeremy renner so we all decide
this is the year we're gonna gang up and
we're gonna get him like kind of last
hurrah sort of thing and it big it was a
true story it came out because this my
character was being interviewed for The
Wall Street Journal about a completely
unrelated subject about his his company
which was some I don't know he ran some
you know fortune 500 company and during
the interview he's sitting down with the
reporter for The Wall Street Journal one
of his friends busts in he jumps up they
start chasing each other around the
table busts out of the office through
the office papers
flying everything the guy finally tags
him and the reporter is like what what
was that thief want to explain that
please it's like I play tag with my
friends we've been doing 30 years anyway
we're we're worried no we're gonna talk
about that for a little bit and he wrote
an article that appeared in The Wall
Street Journal about this is this is
what it is and it became this film and
at Helm's is in it it Helms myself
Jeremy Renner Hannibal Buress Jake
Johnson Annabelle Wallis isla Fisher
Leslie Bibb we have like a great cast
it's really funny and it has a kind of a
sweetheart at the end you know it's like
it's about friendship I mean it's about
you about what you dumb stuff you do
with your friends you know and it's and
it's and it's lovely at the end of the
day and it's and it's and it's it was a
blast to make we've had Jake Johnson on
this show he wore his Mike Ditka sweater
from the 1985 bears so I'm assuming you
had a very nice chat with him about a
card we definitely did we had we had a
lovely we had a lovely friendly rivalry
we would sit and basically watch
baseball games on set I bet and and and
make fun of each other his Ditka sweater
you remember those sweaters yes I do and
and and Ryan and Buddy Ron used to wear
those Bears sweaters
so that's tag and Jun wasn't it funny
don't you think about those sweaters
like did they just not make them big
enough because they were always weirdly
tight right if you think about it that
the stocton shorts too I mean that's
just it's just a different era you know
just a different just don't you think
like they could they could have let it
out a little you know beauty Ryan's a
bigger guy Mike Ditka's a bigger guy get
him get him in the room Beirut in
theaters now tag in theatres June 15th
and then again I'm Amanda to say here on
audience you're on every damn night here
so no it's it's nice to it's nice to be
on the sharing network with you yeah
it's a pleasure and thank you for
allowing me to rip off Don Draper's of
the forum for my mugs we put you on the
Rich Eisen show that now that is look
like Don Draper on on my run smoking
drinking and running
he can do that not spill that is an
impressive move I can't wait for next
year's combine good to see you good to
see you brother
likewise that's Jon Hamm here on the
Rich Eisen show we're off to Dallas
we'll explain what we're doing at the
draft when we come back the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience